[Musique]
pas mal salut les épicurieuses et les
épicurieux je suis sûr que comme moi
vous adorez la pétanque alors évidemment
vous le savez toutes et tous c'est un
jeu typiquement marseillais mais qui a
conquis le cœur de tous les Français en
revanche savez-vous comment la pétanque
a été inventée comment on fait un
carreau pourquoi la boule visée est
éjectée alors que la boule tirée reste
sur place on va tirer tout ça au clair
avec un joueur prestigieux Michel loi
Champion du Monde de Pétanque là il est
en train de s'échauffer et moi je vais
faire la même chose pour ça je dois me
pointer dans l'atelier
[Musique]
pas mal en 2022 la pétanque compte est
exactement
255 590 licenciés en France ça donne le
vertige c'est grosso modo la population
de Bordeaux sans compter toutes celles
et ceux qui comme moi pratiquent ce jeu
pour se détendre pendant leurs vacances
alors je parle d'un jeu mais est-ce un
jeu ou un sport et bien la pétanque est
considérée comme un sport elle possède
sa propre fédération et de nombreuses
compétitions nationales et
internationales sont organisées la toute
première édition du championnat du monde
a eu lieu en 1959 à Spa en Belgique et
sans surprise c'est la France qui domine
la discipline en ayant remporté 27
championnats du monde ce point est en
précisé nous pouvons rejoindre notre
champion du monde Michel loi on a de la
chance aujourd'hui c'est lui qui nous
sert de coach
[Musique]
bonjour Michel bonjour ravi de
rencontrer une légende de la pétanque
alors dites moi on peut jouer soit en
simple soit en équipe on peut jouer un
contre un trois boules chacun en
doublette donc comme le nom l'indique
deux contre deux avec trois bouts de
chacun et en triplette trois joueurs de
chaque côté avec des bouts de chacun
donc 12 boules sur le terrain je peux
jeter un œil sur les boules avec
lesquels vous jouez alors évidemment
elles sont gravées au nom du champion et
on va observer ces boules d'un peu plus
près pour voir comment elles sont
fabriquées je vous la rends merci je
vais faire un tour dans l'atelier et je
reviens aussitôt après à tout à l'heure
à votre avis combien pèse une boule de
pétanque et bien on va le savoir tout de
suite
[Musique]
celle-ci pèse aux alentours de 700 g en
fait les boules de pétanque peste en
moyenne entre 650 et 800 grammes ce
n'est pas très lourd finalement une
brique comme celle-ci fait presque 2 kg
à l'origine une boule de pétanque ça
ressemble à ça c'est un tronçon d'acier
ou de carbone qui a été découpé dans une
pièce beaucoup plus longue on appelle ça
un lopin le pain est chauffé à 1200
degrés puis il est écrasé entre deux
tresses on obtient une galette comme
celle-ci elle est à nouveau chauffée
puis en boutique ce qui permet d'obtenir
une demi-sphère creuse et en assemblant
deux demi-sphères on obtient une boule
de pétanque les boules de pétanque sont
donc
creuse alors ça ne nous vient pas à
l'idée car les traces de soudure ont
disparu cette boule va être
usinée tourner pour faire disparaître
ces traces de soudure puis elle est
polie pour la rendre bien lisse comme
celle-ci son diamètre peut varier
légèrement de 7 à 8 cm et à ce stade il
ne reste plus que l'étape dite du
striage
s'esprits ne sont pas obligatoires mais
plus il y en a plus la boule est freinée
on dit qu'elle stop plus facilement pour
le cochonnet le but ou le bouchon comme
on dit à Marseille c'est plus simple il
est généralement taillé dans du buis un
bois très dur qui lui permet de résister
aux chocs et à l'usure attention il doit
faire 30 mm de diamètre avec une
tolérance de plus ou moins 1 mm
les jeux de boules existent depuis
l'Antiquité pendant longtemps on y
assure toujours dans le sud de la France
mais rien à voir avec la pétanque que
l'on pratique aujourd'hui ces règles
sont assez récentes elles ont été
établies un peu par hasard au début du
20e siècle grâce à un célèbre joueur de
boules atteint de rhumatismes en 1907 un
champion nommé Jules Hugues dit le noir
dispute une partie de boules provençale
à La Ciotat près de Marseille les règles
de ce jeu oblige les participants à
prendre deux ou trois pas d'élan pour
lancer le cochonnet et les boules à une
distance de 15 à 20 mètres à cette
époque les boules ne sont pas encore en
métal elles sont faites en bois et
recouvertes de clous en cuivre ou en
laiton ce jour-là le noir est victime
d'une grosse crise de rhumatismes il ne
peut ni courir ni lancer ses boules très
loin il décide donc de tracer un cercle
sur le terrain de rester les pieds ancré
au sol et de lancer son cochonnet à 5 ou
6 mètres seulement la pétanque était née
mais au fait pourquoi a-t-on nommé ce
nouveau jeu pétanque le terme vient de
l'occitan provençale P qui signifie pied
est en cas qui signifie pieux donnant en
français régional l'expression jouer
pétanque c'est-à-dire avec les pieds
ancrés dans le sol à la différence je
vous le rappelle de l'ancien jeu qui
consistait à courir pour lancer le
cochonnet et les boules celui qui a les
pieds bien ancrés dans le sol c'est
Michel loi notre champion il m'attend
pour me donner une petite leçon
[Musique]
sympa c'était ma boule ah je savais pas
alors quels conseils donneriez-vous un
joueur débutant comme moi aujourd'hui
dimanche mais déjà la position dans le
rond parce que je pense que c'est le
plus important de l'équilibre de sentir
bien dans le rond d'être fléchi sur ses
jambes on va commencer par la
commencement le lancer du cochonnet du
but ou du bouchon faites le bouchon doit
être jeté entre 6 mètres et 10 mètres
pour commencer une semaine avant de
jeter les 12 boules selon si on jouait
en double être en triplette où on fait
la tête les ciboules on appelle ça une
main quand on a fini de jeter toutes les
boules on compte le nombre de points par
équipe marqués et dans à l'intérieur de
la main une fois que le bouchon par
exemple vous jetez le bouchons à 7 m il
peut très bien bouger jusqu'à 20 mètres
sur un tir et là vous jouez jusqu'à 20
mètres si ça dépasse 20 mètres là
apparemment la même est annulée bon je
me lance allez soyons fous et là je vais
donc pointer c'est-à-dire s'approcher le
plus proche possible du cochonnet
[Musique]
oh là là
osaman d'énergie tout ça alors c'est
quoi votre technique à vous moi j'essaye
d'envoyer en général à peu près à ça du
bouchon en envoyant la boule assez haut
en mettant un peu de poignée et en
espérant que la boule après va s'arrêter
là vous pouvez l'envoyer vous lancez en
cloche c'est un très beau geste
d'ailleurs
pas mal bien joué avec un petit bec
comme au billard
excellent vous jouez depuis combien de
temps Michel une petite quarantaine
d'années déjà et vous vous entraînez
souvent non parce que bon j'ai mon
boulot aussi qui fait que je joue quand
même les weekends mais la semaine je
voudrais
[Musique]
comme Michel sont capables de faire
encore plus fort un tir extraordinaire
qu'on appelle le carreau et c'est un
mouvement assez complexe c'est le
maximum qu'on puisse faire quand on tire
c'est à dire que notre boule qui va
sortir notre main va remplacer la boule
le plus près du bouchon en général il va
faire un carreau en remplaçant la boule
qui avait le point initialement c'est à
dire que vous allez éjecter la boule que
vous visez et la vôtre va rester cloué
sur place
[Musique]
on va faire un saut dans l'atelier pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé d'un point
de vue mécanique entre ces deux boules
je reviens tout de suite Michel à tout à
l'heure
le célèbre savant anglais Isaac Newton
qui a vécu à la fin du XVIIe et au début
du 18e siècle a mis en évidence le
phénomène grâce à cet objet un peu
hypnotisant qui désormais porte son nom
un pendule de Newton
à chaque fois il y a un carreau
revenons à la pétanque la boule lancée
par Michel possède une énergie c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie cinétique facile
à retenir dans cinétique il y a ciné
comme dans cinéma une racine grecque qui
signifie mouvement ce qui est le cas de
la boule lancée par Michel elle est en
mouvement sa quantité d'énergie dépend
vous vous en doutez de la vitesse pour
info quand la vitesse est multipliée par
deux l'énergie est multipliée par 4
cette énergie dépend aussi de la masse
de la boule le joueur Michel tir grâce à
un petit coup de poignet il donne un
effet rétro à la boule pour la faire
tourner sur elle-même en marche arrière
l'objectif de Michel c'est de toucher la
boule qu'il souhaite éjecter pleine
bille à ce moment-là toute l'énergie de
la boule tirée est transmise à la boule
visée privée d'énergie la boule tirée
est clouée sur place le quitter fait
rétro l'empêchant en plus de rouler vers
l'avant la boule visée qui vient d'un
seul coup dans ma gaziné de l'énergie
est éjectée c'est ce qu'on appelle un
choc élastique c'est ce qu'ils arrivent
Newton a mis en évidence avec ce pendule
pour montrer la conservation de la
quantité de mouvement et d'énergie
cinétique
Michel il faut combien de temps pour
maîtriser ce geste je pense qu'au départ
il faut sûrement avoir un petit don mais
après comme tous les sports on faut le
travailler le travailler et puis essayer
d'arriver à son maximum il faut un peu
de patience oui c'est sûr c'est sûr
c'est sûr et puis bon de l'entraînement
c'est sûr que c'est l'entraînement au
départ et après être capable de faire ce
qu'on fait à l'entraînement en
compétition c'est ce qui fait aussi la
différence entre peut-être le genre
moyen et après le joueur un peu plus
chevronné qui fait des résultats alors
est-ce que les joueurs jouent toujours
avec les mêmes boules moi c'est toujours
les mêmes boules comme ça au moins je me
dis si je joue pas bien c'est pas à
cause des boules c'est de ma faute mais
beaucoup de joueurs s'adaptent selon les
terrains selon leur position dans la
dans la triplette parce que le meilleur
jeu c'est le triplette à trois vous avez
le pointeur les milieux et le tireur et
selon vous faites milieu ou tireur selon
les terrains les cailloux de la roulette
vous pouvez changer et de poids et de
diamètre mais la boule du tireur n'est
pas forcément la même que celle du
pointeur la logique voudrait que la
boule du tiroir soit plus légère et un
peu plus grosse et pour le pointeur
d'être toujours pour s'adapter au
terrain
logiquement c'est comme ça mais encore
une fois chacun fait comme une alors
quand on est le joueur de pétanque on
doit être bon je dirais à tous les
postes mais vous est-ce qu'il y a un
poste que vous préférez moi quand
j'étais jeune donc j'essaie de me
rappeler j'étais tireur de tête après
j'ai joué un des plus avec un des plus
Fortis donc je me suis adapté au milieu
c'est à dire que normalement ma vraie
place est milieu je pointe et je tire
donc polyvalent
bon en tout cas merci beaucoup Michel
pour ces conseils cette démonstration je
vais m'entraîner tous l'été et promis
quand je suis prêt on fait une partie
pas de souci j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a donné envie de vous mettre ou
vous remettre à la pétanque si vous avez
aimé n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous
abonner je vous souhaite une excellente
fin de journée si vous ne savez pas quoi
faire et bien jouer à la pétanque bonne
semaine et à dimanche prochain chers des
filles curieuses et épicurieux tiens on
devrait organiser un concours de
pétanque épicurieux ça serait une bonne
idée et
sachez en tout cas que le club des
Fontenay-sous-Bois sera toujours là pour
vous ouvrir les portes au plaisir de
vous revoir et je jouerai encore mieux
j'espère